mais d'abord les annonces principal de
la chef de gouvernement hier résumé par
cécile 6e
c'est la priorité absolue du
gouvernement le pouvoir d'achat
présentée dès aujourd'hui en conseil des
ministres le paquet de mesures prévoit
entre autres un bouclier tarifaire sur
le gaz la revalorisation des prestations
sociales ou encore l'indemnité carburant
pour les travailleurs elisabeth bornes
espère voter la loi au coeur de l'été
autre urgence déjà inscrites dans
l'agenda du gouvernement l'écologie dès
le mois de septembre la chef du
gouvernement va lancer une concertation
et chaque ministre aura un plan d'action
parmi les mesures déjà annoncées la
nationalisation d'edf une bonne nouvelle
pour les écologistes du sénat qui
attendent de voir ce que va contenir le
projet on va voir aussi dans de quelle
manière cela est fait parce que si on le
sait aussi pourquoi cette
nationalisation si c'est pour aussi
absorber les pertes notamment liées au
nucléaire mais en tout cas moi c'est on
doit avoir un service public de
l'énergie elisabeth bornes compte aussi
faire du plein emploi l'une de ses
priorités mais n'a pas précisé de
calendrier elle proposera entre autres
la transformation de pôle emploi en
france travaillent l'insertion des
bénéficiaires du rsa et enfin
l'allongement de la durée du travail
grâce à une réforme des retraites mais
elle n'a pas précisé l'âge légal de
départ une démarche habile pour le
président du groupe centriste au sénat
c'est ce qui faisait débat pendant
l'élection présidentielle c'est un des
rares sujets qui a été évoquée puisque
on n'a pas beaucoup parlé de projet est
donc un des rares sujets c'était les
retraites est ce qu'il faisait débat
parce que c'était pas très explicite
c'était l'âge donc là on ne parle pas de
l'âge c'est assez habile donc nous
proposerons qu'on travaille surtout sur
les trimestres à tous enfin la feuille
de route du nouveau gouvernement prévoit
de mettre au coeur de sa politique
l'égalité des chances dans les domaines
de l'école de la santé et du handicap
beaucoup de mesures peu précises pour la
droite c'est net real qui s'interrogent
sur leur financement plusieurs on
aimerait savoir comment ses finances et
parce que pour le moment on a eu un
catalogue de mesures dont certaines sont
positives mais aucune n'est avec un
financement les groupes politiques au
sénat ne sont en tout cas pas parti sur
une opposition de principe
ils suivront le gouvernement au cas par
cas en fonction de l' écoute qui leur
sera accordé voilà on décortique comme
promis le discours de politique générale
d'elisabeth bornes avec mes invités
marion parisé bonjour bienvenue vous
êtes secrétaire générale fondatrice du
cercle de réflexion le millénaire albert
et nous à l'acteur en chef du service
politique du figaro bonsoir ou bonjour
et bienvenue pablo pino vivien bienvenue
à vous aussi responsable éditorial de la
revue regards et lætitia que pas
éditorialiste politique bonsoir à tous
encore une fois quel jugement marion
parisé vous portez sur ce discours
d'elisabeth bornet est ce que pour vous
elle a vraiment marqué
une volonté de changer de méthode elle
est la marque une volonté de changer de
méthode mais qui s'inscrit finalement
dans les dernières annonces de ce
qu'avait dit le président de la
république c'est à dire cette volonté de
faire de la concertation d'aller vers la
main tendue d'impliquer les acteurs les
élus locaux les acteurs du terrain dans
la construction de la politique du
gouvernement ça a été répété à plusieurs
reprises à travers tout son discours par
petites touches sur chaque sujet
quasiment ça a été très de méfait de
manière très précise
mais par contre là où se pose la
question c'est est-ce que c'est
convaincant puisque derrière le
président de la république a déjà avait
déjà dit en décembre dernier j'ai appris
j'ai changé quasiment c'était sans son
leitmotiv à ce moment là mais
aujourd'hui la défiance est tel que ça
va être difficile à faire passer que ce
conseil national de la refondation par
exemple puisse réussir à les combler les
fossés qui se sont créés tout hull en
tout au long du précédent quinquennat je
pense que à berzé nous parce que vous
serez d'accord avec moi ça va surtout se
jouer là sur les premiers textes au
moment où il va s'agir de
oui ou non qu construire ces textes ici
au sénat à l'assemblée en commission
mixte paritaire là on aura tout le monde
aura les mâles encore oui oui oui dès
dès la semaine prochaine on verra
comment se commet peu pourrait se passer
le quinquennat et notamment au parlement
où la droite qui le groupe tels groupes
charnières qui pourrait faire la
majorité ou pas on a du mal à penser
qu'ils sont certains textes à la gauche
pourrait arriver en renfort donc ça va
se jouer plutôt du côté de la droite on
va dire avec le règne de l'abstention
miser sur l'abstention le gouvernement
est mise beaucoup là dessus soit sur
l'ascension du rn 66 ont des leurs soit
pas donc absent sur n'est pas soutien
mais ça permet de passer ça va se passer
puisque sa baisse le seuil messieurs et
de majorité donc effectivement on va
voir comment comment ce ces propositions
faites par l'exécutif et notamment par
des bandes hier votre attention on sait
bien que de toute façon il n'y aura pas
de pacte de majorité il aura pas de
coalition les l air comme la gauche ne
veulent pas en entendre parler donc ça
va se jouer au cas par cas en fonction
des textes les exigences sont assez
fortes du côté de la droite on l'a vu
puisque sorti en exclusivité la lettre
que vous alliez merlex a adressée à
elisabeth bornes où il réclamait en
termes de pouvoir d'achat un litre litre
d'essence a bloqué à 1 euro 50 la csg
annulé pour veloso cg annulé pour les
pour les personnes âgées enfin junio
revalorisation du travail par rapport à
l'assistanat donc que c'est pas rien et
est sur la gauche apprend aussi est elle
aussi donc ça va être ça va être
compliqué de leur ouvreur pas satisfaire
tous en même temps sur chaque texte
impossible et ce qu'il faut se dire qu
en fonction des textes on pourrait elle
pour
la méthode annoncé on la connaissait f1
c'était oui moi j'ai le sentiment que l
a martelé alors pour l'instant on en est
au stade des mots et des expressions
mais j'ai eu vraiment le sentiment dans
son attitude dans les mots qu'elle a
choisi elle a vraiment tendu la main oui
il y avait une volonté de s'ouvrir façon
pouvait-elle faire autrement sans doute
effectivement on est bien d'accord pablo
pino vivien ce qu'on se dit tous depuis
le
19 juin ce second tour des législatives
sait qu'on est rentré dans une nouvelle
phase une nouvelle donne de notre vie
politique peut être qu'il faut que nous
aussi commentateurs ont réussi ça
changeait un peu notre logiciel
d'analysé est-ce que vous avez vu l'
amorce de ça aussi dans le discours des
abonnements mais aussi les réactions des
uns et des autres après en fait vous
avez mis l'accent effectivement sur la
méthode plus que sur le fond
effectivement moi c'est aussi ce que
j'ai entendu est là elle essaye en fait
de trouver alors pas forcément une
méthode mais de dire qu'elle a une
méthode parce qu'en fait je pense que
son objectif aujourd'hui comme tout le
monde le dit ça va être très compliqué
dans la mesure où c'est une des
premières fois qu'on n'a pas de majorité
absolue à l'assemblée nationale en fait
ils vont elles cherchent un moyen en
fait de rejeter la patate chaude sur un
éventuel blocage en fait parlementaire
et donc elle veut dire bon bah écoutez
moi en tout cas en tant que chef de
gouvernement je fais le maximum on va
faire texte par texte et après s'il ya
un blocage ce sera de votre faute ce
sera pas de la mienne parce que moi
j'aurais vraiment fait le maximum et
c'est là c'est ce qu'elle a annoncé
parce que en vérité lorsqu'on prend les
différentes mesures qu'elle a qu'elle a
annoncé c'est peu ou prou tout ce qu'a
annoncé emmanuel macron pendant sa
campagne présidentielle et une sur
hyères ensuite une fois qu'il a été au
rhénus n'y a pas vraiment de grande
nouvelle à par la dea conjugale isation
de la hache sur lequel on reviendra
peut-être ou là c'est un peu une
nouveauté enfin c'est pas non plus c'est
très important mais c'est pas non plus
central on va dire pour mener à bien une
action gouvernementale alors il ya quand
même la renationalisation d'edf marion
parisé a c'est une annonce importante
même si on s'y attendait c'est ça on s'y
attendait parce que depuis quelques
temps on avait une
entreprise qui était vraiment malade 1
fondamentalement qui accumule les dettes
etc mais qui à être cumule les dettes
aussi un peu d'une certaine contrainte
et forcée par l'état et forcée par
l'état donc on peut éventuellement même
je pensais que c'était une stratégie
pour fragiliser cette entreprise et la
re nationaliser finalement à moindre
coût dans une logique qui est très
simple d'une part il ya la possibilité
ensuite de pouvoir investir plus
facilement dans le parc nucléaire pour
aujourd'hui pour alors qu'il ya eu des
engagements assez fort du président de
la république sur des nouveaux
nucléaires et le nucléaire de petite
taille etc qui souvent être développée
il ya un besoin de pouvoir avoir le
poids de la puissance publique derrière
l'entreprise et sa capacité
d'investissement mais ce qui se pose
comme question on sait comment cette
nationalisation pourrait se faire est ce
que on va passer par simplement un
rachat qui seraient des pour bien ça va
coûter lorsque c'est aussi une question
à vous maintenant maintenant qu'ils
tombent donc c'est messi s'est passé pas
énorme en fait un pli effectivement
comme vous l'avez dit l'entreprise a
perdu
ramener aux 3000 milliards d'aidés
publiques effectivement c'est 1000 2006
le processus va jouer puisque on a le
choix finalement entre une
nationalisation qui sera fait par une
loi de nationalisation et dans ce cas là
il y aura négociation il y aura
discussion avec le parlement qui ne sera
pas forcément évident et potentiellement
aussi des oppositions qui voudront
obtenir des contreparties j'imagine bien
là du ps vouloir obtenir des
contreparties peut-être sur les
questions écologiques dans ce cadre là
mais de l'autre option c'est le rachat
unes à unes départ qui serait sans doute
peut-être un peu mieux acceptée parce
que avec moins le symbolique de la re
nationalisation forcée qui a le côté
expropriations mais dont le coût n'est
pas aussi certain puisqu'il faudra
négocier avec chacun des actionnaires
évidemment mais c'est intéressant pablo
parce que ça ça ne peut que plaire c'est
pas au parti communiste par exemple
al'annonce là donc c'est vous voyez ce
que je veux dire la la la la ça peut
être un signe lancé à une partie de la
nuit vous avez tout à fait raison sauf
que entre temps enfin il ya quelques
semaines quelques mois il ya la revue
contexte en fait qui a mis à jour un
projet qui était portée à priori au plus
haut niveau de l'exécutif quel projet
recul est en fait qu'un projet de
démantèlement d'edf qui n'est que en
fait cette renationalisation servirait à
démanteler ensuite dh c'est à dire al
séparés en gros revendre les les
structures qui sont le plus rentable au
sein d'edf je pense notamment à inédit
s'ouvrir le capital des néo 10 et puis à
30 ou 40 % et on sait ensuite se
concentrer sur les activités finalement
déficitaire et donc continuer
d'accroître finalement la dette
chronique d'edf donc et ça je peux vous
dire que c'est pas bien vu ni par la cgt
ni par le pcf ni par la cgt la cgt
alerte depuis très longtemps ils sont
présents dans l'est dans l'est dans les
titres dans la direction d'edf dans les
comités exécutifs etc et ils sont pas du
tout contents de faim oui papa de
renationalisation d'ailleurs il parle de
ré étatisation albert et nous un mot
là-dessus et ensuite on va avancer il ya
un enjeu de souveraineté en tout cas
c'est le discours affiché par l'exécutif
de toute façon il y avait y avait une
quasi nationalisation de fait avec la
dette générée par l'état donc il fallait
absolument que qu'il fallait prendre en
compte cette dette colossale et que
l'état entraîne donc mais effectivement
je pense que il ya ya risque ou une
chance c'est pas sa place mais
effectivement edf soit soit soit
démantelé il ya je pense que dans la
dans la tête d'un libéral comme comme
emmanuel macron n'ya pas la volonté de
revenir avant 81 ou par nationaliser
complètement odf et et mettre des
fonctionnaires partout donc
à voir là dedans la discussion mais je
je je crois bien qu'il ya des activités
qui pourraient passer rester dans le
privé juste un petit mot c'est 80
aujourd'hui l'état faut rappeler
agrémente ses 84 % des besoins d'edf
dont il ya que 16% a racheté un peu
effectivement et donc ça veut dire que
je suis l'actionnaire qui décide de la
stratégie de l'avenir de l'efs c'est
déjà l'état bref
laetitia ce discours de politique
générale vous l'avez regardé sous
l'angle du spectacle politique et on
peut se demander si le spectacle n'a pas
pris le pas sur la politique disons que
j'avais un oeil qui allait à la fois sur
le fond et la forme je n'ai pas regardé
uniquement sous l'angle du spectacle et
c'est le spectacle qu'il a effectivement
emporté pourquoi on vient de le dire ici
on a parlé depuis cinq minutes de cette
nationalisation d'edf qui finalement 16%
si c'est pas un changement phénoménale
et donc la première ministre bien sûr
est déjà la première responsable du
spectacle que les français ont pu voir
quand il regardait évidemment pourquoi
parce que son texte était creux mince
politiquement très peu d'annoncés fortes
et bien sûr la deuxième raison du
triomphe de ce spectacle c'est
l'agitation
organisée préparée minutieusement par la
france insoumise à la fois à l'intérieur
mais aussi à l'extérieur de l'hémicycle
il ya une séquence thomas qui a tourné
en boucle parce qu'il ya uniquement un
français sur deux qui a regardé et les
avais bande qui a été touchée par ce
discours de politique générale mais tous
certainement ont vu de cette image
happening d'un mariage singer entre
emmanuel macron et
le pen et c'était donc à l'extérieur de
l'assemblée nationale je vous propose de
regarder tout petit extrait
my name voulez vous prendre pour époux
emmanuel ma
[Applaudissements]
séquence assumé par les députés de la
france a soumis sur les plateaux ensuite
ça a tourné sur toutes les chaînes
d'info en continu cette séquence ils ont
dit que c'était pour signifier la fin du
pacte républicain est aussi la porosité
de la majorité avec le rassemblement
national certes mais c'est je voudrais
en fait se soit posé la question est ce
que le spectacle l'agit-prop sert la
politique est ce que ce genre de
happening va se répéter pendant cinq ans
pendant tout le quinquennat d'emmanuel
macro est ce que ça n'éloigne pas encore
un peu plus le citoyen de la politique
et je ne voyais pas uniquement la
responsabilité du parti de jean luc
mélenchon mais aussi des médias et plus
particulièrement des chaînes d'info en
continu parce que encore une fois c'est
une séquence qui a été diffusée partout
et ça a été une séquence presque
maîtresse dans le debriefing du discours
d isabelle borne pourtant ça reste un
épiphénomène l'agitation et le lieu
majeur c'est l intérieur de l'assemblée
évidemment oui parce qu'il y avait aussi
un brouhaha organisé pendant tout le
discours d'elisabeth baume par la france
insoumise regardez un extrait nous
devrons soutenir les soignants le coc
vide a mis à jour les fragilités de
notre système de soins
[Applaudissements]
vous plaît
il a aussi montré l'engagement
exceptionnel de nos soignants et je veux
leur rendre hommage
des chapeaux l'oeil s'il vous plaît
pas de telles manifestations dans
l'hémicycle s'il vous plaît
[Musique]
ce qu'il faut noter thomas c'est la
différence de comportement des députés
du rassemblement national qui eux ont
simplement dodeliner de la tête ou voilà
feu des moûts peut-être un peu
dubitative mais n'ont pas crié par
exemple hypocrite non pas une et marine
le pen quand elle a pris la parole elle
est quand même allé sur le style sur la
forme puisqu'elle indique emmanuel
macron se mettait en scène en sauveur du
monde je la cite comme si l'exercice du
pouvoir devait se réduire à une
bande-son netflix elle a dénoncé un
pouvoir irrémédiablement narcissique
alors oui thomas s'était dit ce soir
pour vous dire que nous sommes entré
définitivement dans l'ère du populisme
et donc la forme risque de primer sur le
fond pour le reste du quinquennat et on
a en gros un centre droit et puis deux
parties iconoclaste je ne suis pas là
pour donner des sons et mais bon juste
pour pointer encore une fois la
responsabilité des politiques et des
médias parce que nous sommes
journalistes et nous ne sommes pas
obligés d'être captif de ces happenings
et de la mise en scène constante qui va
être fait certainement de la politique
pour les cinq années à venir les gens
des enjeux sanitaires économiques
écologiques sont colossaux je vous
rappelle qu emmanuel macron a promis une
méthode nouvelle où les français
seraient appelés à discuter ensemble
pour décider des grandes orientations
politiques et il me semble que ce
spectacle fait tout pour les en
dissuader alors pour rebondir si on
déduire l'on va pas passer cinq minutes
à discuter de ce faux mariage moi je les
trouvais pathétique en un mot bon petit
aimable au fait ça veut quand même dire
quelque chose c'est à dire que en fait
la stratégie aujourd'hui de la france en
soumises et c'est de faire sienne la
colère du peuple ce qu'ils imaginent je
fais canaliser je me permettrais pas de
juger mais c'est ça ils veulent
représenter le peuple dans sa colère
c'est pour ça qu'en fait ils font du
broc à l'assemblée par an et c'est pour
ça qu'ils font ils font ce ce carnaval
sur la place du palais bourbon et tout
ça en fait participe d'une espèce de
d'adéquation en fait qu'ils veulent
entre eux représentant du peuple et le
peuple alors effectivement parce que moi
je voulais qu'on en tire des leçons
parce que c est ce qu on va voir ça pour
savourer un mandature ça présage une une
mandature tous les cas compliqués avec
avec une énergie propre et à l'intérieur
et à l'extérieur des hémicycles là ce
qu'on a vu c'est pas du tout ça grandit
pas la politique quand on voit les
insoumis qui systématiquement n'écoute
pas la première ni smrz suis pas là pour
la défendre mais mais ne font que que
crier hurler
lancer des invectives c'est que c'est un
passionné c'est un peu vieux comme le
enfin comme l'assemblée
de politique on laisse au moins le
premier ministre s'est exprimé ça dure
une heure en général on est après
viendra le temps de la discussion plus
vive genre les verbatim de ce qui se
passait pour la troisième république
c'était retrait non plus violents
il n'y avait pas ce spectacle-là en tous
les cas et c'est ce ce bois là c'est en
direct tout le monde l'entend
d'entraîner le public s'était déroulé
relais c'était les relais dans la presse
et dans les journaux donc c'est à moi ce
que je trouvais ce que j'ai trouvé un
peu
minable de la part de l efi par exemple
c'est de ne pas avoir salué l'action des
policiers et des gendarmes quand la
première ministre dit parle de la honte
de ce qu'ils attaquent physiquement les
policiers et les gendarmes
tout le monde s'est levé et a applaudi
et les filles n'ont pas du tout mais
alors que la sécurité alors même que la
série des protestaires bien de tous les
français fins et les blés les policiers
sur la et les gendarmes sont là pour
protéger les français mais d'ailleurs
sur cette phrase là est la première
ministre a ajouté un tacle immédiatement
après à l'aller fille en ajoutant on a
ceux qui tentent de monter les français
contre ceux qui les protègent et là on
était directement dans l' attaque
frontale contre exactement ce qu'ils se
soient pas donc merce mais il veut être
avait-il anticipé je n'irai pas jusque
là mais c'est la nature de la relation
qu'il faut interroger est ce que ce sera
une opposition frontale systématique
quel que soit le projet de loi quelle
que soit le discours ce qui pose
problème quand on veut se poser en
alternance en alternative possible pour
2027 par exemple parce que il faut aussi
crédibiliser le fait que l efi peut-être
potentiellement un parti de gouvernement
s'opposait aussi qu'il ya une manière de
marquer le coup oui marque le coup la
première à la première séance et bien
progresser ciel et puis après peut-être
que ça se calme on n'avait pas
l'impression me respectabilité peut être
une stratégie politique et d'ailleurs je
crois que c'est aujourd'hui de ce qu'ils
veulent faire d'autant plus que là ils
sont dans le cadre d'institutions qui
dans une certaine mesure ni puisque ils
veulent passer à la 6ème république à 6
ans sur les intérêts s'ils
l'attaquent contre les journalistes par
exemple systématique
mélenchon l'assumé complètement que oui
mais alors en guerre c'est pas le
premier mois je me suis en campagne
électorale avec françois bayrou
violent que 36
l'elysée ségolène royal les attaques
contre les journalistes si on n'allait
quand même pas mal bref une époque on
faisait une émission qui s'appelait
médias le mag donc on est un peu
sensible là dessus pas chez adacore à
laquelle gaza on avait aussi des ébats
d'ailleurs alors au c'ur sur cette
histoire de stratégie notamment trash
chine la dupe c'est intéressant parce
que en miroir ça nous permet d'évaluer
celle du rn je vous propose d'écouter
marine le pen elle était ce matin sur
rtl je n'ai pas pour objectif de faire
sauter les institutions j'ai pour
objectif de faciliter la vie des
français vous parlez de qui là de faire
beau je parle par exemple de l'extrême
gauche je suis là pour faire en sorte
que le travail paie que la sécurité
revienne dans les rues que le pouvoir
d'achat augmente et nous allons
travailler pour cela mais nous allons
travailler avec la fermeté que l'on nous
connaît avec la force de conviction qui
est celle du rassemblement national
marion parisé c'est la laine est ce que
la nuque ne facilite pas finalement la
stratégie de marine le pen là il joua
plus républicaine que moi tu meurs c'est
tout à fait ça en fait on est un
contraste très très brusque entre des
élus de l efi en particulier les filles
qui se sont fait élire sur une
opposition quasi révolutionnaire et qui
du coup ci il commence à être dans une
attitude constructive vont être
finalement vidés de leur sens et un rn
qui est lui dans une tentative
d'institutionnalisation déjà depuis
plusieurs années et qui aujourd'hui veut
se montrer comme finalement étant en
mesure de pouvoir exercer le pouvoir
parce qu'il parle de beaucoup plus loin
aussi historiquement les filles est
beaucoup plus jeune et avait encore une
une histoire où ils ne sont pas marquées
comme un parti inapte à gouverner alors
que le rn jusqu'à très récemment n'était
même pas envisageable aujourd'hui ils
sont en train de rattraper ça et
d'essayer de passer ce dernier pas et je
pense que c'est dans ce sens là quelques
la stratégie de marine le pen s'exerce à
berne le renne un déficit colossal en
terme de deux partis de gouvernement ne
l'incarné pas cette capacité a auprès
des français auprès des électeurs
notamment les plus âgés deux d'être
celui qui pourrait être dirigé la france
marine le pen à ceux à ce problème là et
qu'elle ne fait pas ou ne soit pas
sérieuse comme présidente donc les
français ne la crédite pas d'une
capacité à gouverner là elle retrouve va
il trouve un axe un axe très intelligent
de leur part de ceux ans
institutionnalisant en étant le versant
le versant raisonnable de la nuque s&d
de trouver des axes de conciliation de
compromis même
le premier temps a été d'avoir d'avoir
d'avoir retiré son candidat à l'élection
de la présidente de l'assemblée c'était
un signe déjà qu' il y avait une volonté
d'aller vers quelque part de ben laden
aussi l'argument
de ce mariage bidon enfin vous voyez ce
que je veux dire de derrière elle
finalement je me trouve un jeu de mail
vermeren leur haine à une volonté
absolue d'aller convaincre que ils
peuvent diriger la france et que en 2027
ils peuvent être le parti la fable le
candidat de l'ani d'induire est peut
être celui qui peut diriger la france et
en ça s'est il faut donner des gages de
ne pas être dans la vie active et dans
la surenchère pablo pino vivien il ya
aussi dans cette stratégie nous vers la
stratégie de la nuque il ya quand même
aussi un risque qu'une partie des alliés
ne se sentent pas à l'aise avec cette
opposition on va dire frontale ou cette
obstruction systématique oui dont mais
ça c'est tout à fait juste jeu pour
l'instant les alliés notamment je pense
que vous pensez aux socialistes et aux
idéaux communistes ont l'air de plutôt
suivre dans la mesure où au départ par
exemple n'était pas hyper d'accord avec
la question de la motion de censure et
puis finalement ils ont ils vont tous
voter comme un seul homme et comme une
seule femme d'ailleurs de lundi prochain
après je voudrais juste rappeler quelque
chose lundi à 16h lundi à ce vote
commence il faut il faut il faut pas
confondre
l'ordre et la république ce sont deux
choses différentes je tiens à rappeler
que quand même on a on a eu cinq
républiques en france on est dans la
cinquième il ya au moins deux
républiques qui sont nés dans des
révolutions et que aujourd'hui
l'objectif de 2 de jean luc mélenchon
c'est précisément de porter la sixième
république et donc la question de du
bordel en fait je le dit vulgairement
mais cette question en fait il est il
essaye aussi de générer ce bordel pour
rendre la situation impossible
et ensuite faire que la seule issue en
fait soit la sixième république qu'il
appelle de ses voeux qu'il a théorisé
qui est très bien qui est très bien dans
le programme qui est
halal y aura du droit dans l'assemblée
nationale que la france deviendra
ingouvernable enfin c'est c'est vraiment
dans la stratégie de jean luc mélenchon
c'est la prophétie auto réalisatrice qui
ne fonctionne pas dans son cas il nous a
dit qu'il serait à matignon il n'est pas
à matignon il nous a dit qu'il y aura
une cohabitation n'y a pas de
cohabitation mai
d'accord mais il faut aussi un peu
prendre respecter les électeurs ont
semble-t-il de secteurs ils ont voté je
pense pour une sixième république par
exemple les électeurs deux sélecteurs de
la nouvelle star dont les acteurs de la
nuit seulement
dans le prendre de la vitesse alors les
laisser une autre façon de dire les
mêmes choses que vous ne pourrez pas le
même mot mais les insoumis sont-ils dans
l'arc républicain on peut on peut le
dire comme ça et c'est la question qui a
été posée ce matin au ministre de
l'éducation nationale il était l'invité
de la matinale de france inter voici ce
que pap ndiaye répondent les insoumis
par certaines de leurs expressions et
certaines de leurs veilles mance me
paraissent en situation en tout cas
limites du point de vue de cet arc
démocratique et républicain on va faire
un peu de sémantique politique ensemble
si vous le voulez bien albert et nous
elle est fille comme et rennes réfute le
mau extrême oui ni extrême gauche et
extrême droite est ce qu'on ne nous au
journaliste on est obligé de les
suivants nom vous dit quoi vous nous on
est on est
on
se qualifie pas je qualifie pas le front
national à l'assemblée nationale
d'extrême droite si on n'ose y en a mais
on peut enfin je ne critique pas ce qui
est de ceux qui le font
l'extrême droite ça correspond à quelque
chose de bien précis qui remet en cause
les institutions qui remet en cause la
république et qui cherche à établir un
projet un mode de gouvernement
autoritaire
par la force et qui rejette beaucoup des
valeurs républicaines or jusqu'à présent
leur usine faisant le rassemblement
national d'aujourd'hui on parle pas du
passé du front national et respecte
enfin de vêtements
verson assad respectent les lois de la
république ils ceux qui vont aux
élections si les pères dit vrai et un
faux nez je vais décider perdent ils
reconnaissent leur leur défaite ils sont
pas ils jouent ils jouent le jeu
républicain social que dans l'extrême
droite porte à voir le drapeau bleu
blanc rouge c'était une infamie c'était
la gueuse la république on ne voulait
pas au cracher dessus jusqu'au jusqu'en
62 le général de gaulle était été jugé
comme comme comme attentatoire à la la
la france faisait tct c'était terrible
donc la cia il y avait une véritable
extrême droite aujourd'hui c'est une
droite nationaliste certes
pas autoritaire mais en tous les cas qui
est qui qui en tant qu' en tant qu il ya
des des valeurs qui ont un effet
respecter des valeurs mais on peut pas
dire qu'il soit ce soit hors d'eau hors
du champ républicain l'art est une
manière que le défi n'est pas hors du
champ républicain et donc vous vous
qualifiez pas les fines extrême gauche
non plus nous parties une partie d'une
une partie du
groupe et les filles qui peut être
catégorisés d'extrême gauche là pour le
coup une partie du groupe elle est fille
bas de la nuque qu'est ce que vous en
pensez marion paris v je pense sur le
plan du choix est ce que les filles
elles et rennes sont dans l'arc
républicain elisabeth bornes je trouve
clairement énoncé son choix en tout cas
ils vivent elles thinon puisque les
manceaux ne pas c'est ça elle est là
c'était assez subtil d'ailleurs elle
fait signe à tous les autres partis en
six ans les groupes les présidents de
groupe ou président du groupe mais pas
pour le fn et elfi et dans le sur le
plan vraiment des actions je vous
rejoins sur le cas du r n en effet
aujourd'hui ils respectent les règles de
la république ils s'inscrivent dedans ça
a été même un travail qui nous ont menés
c'est leur histoire finalement qu'
aujourd'hui
continue à déteindre sur leur image et
qui tend à les présenter comme une
extrême droite alors qu'aujourd'hui ils
n'ont ils sont plus ou moins dans l'arc
républicain ils sont une droite vraiment
très à droite mais ils ne sont pas sont
pas anti républicain pourrait les filles
la question se pose sur plusieurs points
il ya quand même une contestation de la
légitimité de l'état une volonté de
remettre en cause la république des
contestations de considérer la
préférence nationale par exemple si on
parle du rassemblement national c'est
dans l'arc républicain ça va alors
préférence nationale ça peut être dans
une certaine mesure si on parle
spécifiquement du côté économique par
exemple on parle si on parle de la du
patriotisme économique
aujourd'hui c'est un enjeu alors
peut-être qu'il faut évoluer sur les
définitions aussi aujourd'hui ces temps
dangereux que beaucoup de pays assume
parce que les enjeux et les
problématiques actuelles sont
différentes de celles d'il ya 20 ans
aujourd'hui le patriotisme économique
il est devenu quasiment nécessaire dans
un état où le tissu économique est
complètement délité face à des à des
concurrences qui ne sont pas maîtrisés
mais mais ça aujourd'hui est-ce que ça
suffit pour du coup on voudrait définir
des neiges il faut il faut commencer par
définir en fait ce que c'est que la
république si la république par exemple
c'est notre constitution ce que veut
faire marine le pen sur les question de
comment est ce qu'on obtient la
nationalité française qu'elle veut faire
au droit d'asile ce qu'elle veut faire
effectivement sur les questions de
priorité nationale c'est totalement en
dehors des clous de la constitution et
d'ailleurs elle a elle même dit elle
veut faire un référendum pour modifier
mais je suis d'accord mais dans ces cas
là excusez moi mais une dans la
définition de la république ça peut être
plein de choses ça peut tout ce que vous
lui ça peut être un projet raciste
xénophobe
complètement autoritaire on peut aussi
imaginer que c'est ça la république mais
ccfa je pense que en dix ans la deuxième
leçon en fait il faut imaginer que tous
les objets dont on parle la démocratie
la république
l'extrême droite sont des objets en fait
qui nécessitent compose des définitions
et qu'ensuite on soit à peu près
d'accord sur les définitions la façon
dont ces utilisé par les hommes
politiques par exemple par pap ndiaye
tout à l'heure ce sont des façons de
d'insultés l'adversaire et de les sortir
du champ de la discussion etc mais mais
c'est tout ça n'a pas ça n'a pas
d'autres buts moi je considère que
l'extrême le rassemblement national est
un parti d'extrême droite parce qu'ils
ne portent pas les valeurs qui sont à
mon sens fondatrice de la république à
savoir la liberté l'égalité et la
fraternité et que je vois pas sur aucun
ces trois points je vois pas où est ce
que la la le rassemblement national en
fait peut se dire républicain pour ce
qui est de la nuit baisse pour ce qui
est de la france insoumise en revanche
ces trois valeurs me semble cardinal
donc je considère qu'elles sont dans le
champ républicain je ne vois pas les
albères et nous avons eu de réponse et
on passe alors le voit une menace est
pas le le triptyque l'égalité et le
droit d'asile par exemple ce qu'ils
veulent faire au droit d'asile c'est à
dire
c'est
que le droit de vouloir de droit d'asile
aussi que la ville ait réellement
détourné de sa fonction première était
protéger les personnes les gens qui
rendent qu'avant car oui pourquoi
attendait aujourd'hui on voit bien que
les demandeurs les vendeurs de droit
d'asile ne sont plus mais réfugiés
politiques les demandeurs d'asile ou
ceux qui ont obtenu l'asile sa part l
intention liste demandeur et ça donne
plein de monde mais je mettrais bien
attention très peu très peu de
demandeurs obtiennent le droit d'asile
ils sont déboutés et son jeu ne sont
jamais renvoyé mais tout ça c'est pas la
question du droit d'asile
apprécié mes formes et le droit d'asile
et on va pas se lancer dans un débat sur
le grenelle il même s'il est passionnant
on a déjà évoqué cette question je note
quand même une différence c'est
qu'aujourd'hui le rn veut changer des
règles sur lequel il compte est
effectivement là fonctionnement de du
droit d'asile ou d'autres aspects mais
ils veulent le changer par les
institutions aujourd'hui ce que fait
jean luc mélenchon c'est de monter la
rue contre les institutions c'est
l'exemple de justement qui a été
fait la rue sauvé se situe rassemblement
national montre que le rassemblement
national à gagner évidemment tout le
monde car devant les journalistes
remettait ça en cause avant on voit bien
qu'il y à une heure le champ là cette
falaise ouverte elle a vraiment grandi
et qu'aujourd'hui le front national et
est à la lisière pour certains il est à
l'intérieur pour d'autres encore alex
allez on va parler du parti et l'air
tout de suite alexandre poussin peut
nous rejoindre tout de suite sur ce
plateau et on va se concentrer bonsoir
sur ce qui s'est passé hier soir ici au
céda puisque devant les sénateurs la
première ministre a insisté sur sa
méthode de travail pour trouver des
compromis très bien thomas on peut dire
qu elisabeth borgne a fait une sorte de
déclaration d'amour politique à la haute
assemblée au sénat qui représente selon
elle l'apaisement à l' équilibre dans
les institutions et la première ministre
a même dit vouloir s'inspirer de la
méthode du sénat dans la fabrication de
la loi c'est-à-dire la recherche du
compromis entre les différentes forces
politiques on va l'écouter
bâtir des solutions ensemble
en écoutant les propositions de tous en
s'appuyant sur nos territoires en
restant fidèles à nos valeurs c'est la
méthode du sénat depuis longtemps nous
devons nous inspirer de l'expérience et
des pratiques du sénat
[Applaudissements]
à l'heure où notre et 28
et voilà il y avait une très bonne
ambiance entre la première ministre et
les sénateurs alors le gouvernement veut
tellement travaillé main dans la main
avec le sénat que les projets de loi et
il avait des bandes l'annoncé des
projets de loi pourrait plus souvent
être examiné en premier par le sénat
avant d'arriver à l'assemblée nationale
écoutez
mon gouvernement partage avec vous bon
nombre de priorités et même sans aucun
doute de solutions dans certains
domaines et pour certains textes au delà
de ce que la constitution prévoit le
travail parlementaire pourra commencer
dans cet hémicycle avant de se prolonger
à l'assemblée nationale ainsi le sénat
pourra pleinement agir comme force de
co-construction au service des
territoires et des français alors ça n'a
l'air de rien comme ça mais c'est
important dans le travail parlementaire
car quand le sénat examinera en premier
un texte il pourra davantage influer sur
le projet loi le modifier trouver en
premier des compromis avec le
gouvernement et ensuite le texte modifié
arrivera à l'assemblée nationale alors
forcément cette annonce et bien elle a
ravi à la majorité de droite sénatoriale
c'était une un souhait très fort
exprimée par le président du sénat donc
on va voir quelle sera la teneur de ces
textes et comment effectivement on
pourra nous d'emblée de donner notre
marque oc au texte avant qu'il n'arrive
à l'assemblée nationale on l'a déjà fait
mais on faisait essentiellement sur les
textes touchant aux collectivités
territoriales je pense plus
particulièrement à la loi 3ds là il est
important que ce soit des textes de
nature différente qui puisse d'abord
être débattue voter a demandé d'abord
est voté au sénat alors attention
derrière ce changement de méthode
parlementaire il est aussi de la
tactique politique de la part de
l'exécutif car quand on réfléchit bien
un projet de loi qui ferait à dabo
l'objet d'un compromis entre la majorité
de droite sénatoriale et le gouvernement
une fois qu'il arrivera à l'assemblée
nationale eh bien pour les députés les
républicains ce sera plus compliqué de
le rejeter et on sait qu emmanuel macron
durant ce quinquennat aura grandement
besoin des voix des députés a l'air
merci beaucoup alexandre poussard albert
et nous on ça nous promet un quinquennat
qui va peut-être encore un peu plus
penché à droite que le premier de la
mesure où
l'exécutif a besoin des voix de la
droite pour faire passer beaucoup de
textes et des textes importants comme
les retraites par exemple
je pense en me tromper que c'est pas
avec leur assemblée nationale et hélas
du ps qu il trouvera des alliés forts et
puissants pour aller faire passer le
texte sur les retraites
d'autant que les deux que ce soit soit
l'exécutif ou où la droite veut aller
plutôt du on n'a pas compris avec le
discours de politique générale donc on
sait pas ce qu'ils veulent dans ton cas
c'était un peu plus donc on ira
travailler plus elle a pas pris le
risque de redonner
aux
milliers de voix
midi sonne la majorité 4 la droite est
plutôt autour de 64 65 aussi donc il
peut y avoir des payer voire d entente
là dessus mais ça va être peut être
évident de trouver des compromis comme
cela qu avec les évêques bornes c'est un
début de méthode quand elle veut faire
une opération séduction à hiva franco
c'est à dire que c'était vraiment très
que c'était l'illustration
très nette d'un peu chaud un sourire les
familles concernées
sont les présidents
mais plutôt ce pays je pense qu'il y
avait aussi le soulagement de ne pas
être dans la même ambiance que quelques
l'assemblée sable ça a peut-être joué
mais si on est sur le la fois sur le
fond et la tactique politique dans un
entretien au midi libre gérard larcher
lui même temps la main aux gouvernants
il propose une nouvelle méthode ici
propose que les textes soient discutés
avant leur présentation en conseil des
ministres est exactement ce que voilà ça
sert aux gens on peut imaginer que ça a
été un peu un peu discuté avant
marion parisé pardon
c'est quoi ces des tractations qui ont
eu lieu et qui s'exprime là avec cette
séquence est assez étonnante que elle il
semble tout cela des nouveautés ce
moment ce sourire la petite blague de
gérard larcher ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire qu'ils se sont parlés avant que
cette histoire de navette parlementaire
a été négocié alors ils se sont
probablement parlé avant est ce qu'ils
sont arrivés à un accord sur exactement
quelle est l avis définitif j'en doute
mais après ce sont des personnalités
politiques qui savent dans quelle dans
quel cadre ils interagissent et qui sont
capables aussi de comprendre les signaux
subtil leur choix d'envoyer dans
j'aurais passé
mais pas le groupe l air en entier exact
bien sûr qu'il faut mettre des coins
dans le groupe pour aller chercher
quelques députés et marion pardon nous
avons interrompu mais ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est que le le
pouvoir heller il est aussi très
important ici au sénat oui
nombre tout simplement si on compare à
l'assemblée donc joué la carte du sénat
aient l'air c'est aussi une façon
d'influer sur les députés aient l'air on
peut penser ça c'est la grande de la
grande tentative puisque la coalition a
échoué et la stratégie de la coalition
avaient échoué que un mine je crois que
c'était eric dupond moretti qui a assumé
de dire en finis les débauchages
individuels et je pense que le
gouvernement est très conscience qu'ils
ne peuvent plus essayer de gagner un
l'ensemble du groupe et leur part des
petites personnes mais plutôt de devoir
réussir à avoir un accord du groupe et
dans ce sens là ils sont en effet obligé
de tendre la main au sénat qui sinon on
sera en mesure et lui pour le coup de
bloquer totalement les discussions sur
les projets puisque il y aura des
difficultés à mettre en place des
commissions paritaires qui puisse
vraiment là sujet des conclusions après
il ya une difficulté c'est
qu'aujourd'hui les nerfs ils sont quand
même très divisé sur à la fois leur
stratégie et sur le fond hier j'étais
sur le plateau d'une chaîne concurrente
et on avait un député l air qui disait
qu'en gros lui voulait pas d'allongement
de l'âge de départ à la retraite et ils
disaient on lui a dit mais ne vous êtes
pas d'accord avec avec madame
valérie pécresse ni avec votre problème
il a dit ben oui on a le droit quand
même d'avoir on est des individus on a
le droit d'avoir des opinions
personnelles donc ça on va voir aussi
comment ça ce qui se joue en internat et
l'air ils vont élire quand même et un
nouveau à nouveau leader ou une nouvelle
leader on va voir comment ça va se
passer quelles options en fait ils vont
choisir entre les différentes qui leur
sont proposés merci beaucoup à tous
d'avoir participé à ce premier débat